any communications whether it's a
website
or a video or even a circus requires
knowing your audience and adjusting the
presentation to them
for instance you're doing a circus it's
for kids of course you're going to go
full on ringling brothers with lions and
tigers and bears and clowns
but if you have a more sophisticated
audience you might have a little more
nuance and artistry
a little more cirque du soleil than
ringling brothers
what do we need to know about our
audience for visualization
it's really the same as for any
communications challenge
we need to understand their culture
their level of expertise
and a few other things first culture
your audience comes from a certain place
in the world
it affects their language it affects
their perspective it affects their
context
so many different things for example
think about
what does a wedding look like sometimes
it looks like this or like this or like
this
it affects the colors that are used
color theory is its own big conversation
that we're not going to cover in detail
in this course
but culture is an important influence on
color amongst other things
for instance what does a wedding dress
look like
is it white is it red
and remember that what looks odd in one
culture might be completely normal in
another one
another thing culture influences is
narrative context
does your audience know the underlying
story of what you're talking about
for instance let's say you're creating a
visualization of wayne gretzky
statistics
wayne gretzky was probably the greatest
hockey player who ever lived
if you're doing this visualization for
people in northern countries who play a
lot of hockey
you probably don't need to set a lot of
context
you don't need to explain who wayne
gretzky is
but if it's a visualization for people
in maybe brazil or madagascar
they might not have as much of that
context
you might need to set up the story a
little bit better for them
the next one is level of expertise if
you're creating a project and it's for
people who are experts in an industry
you're going to approach it in one way
less context
less handholding maybe even use
different language
different types of words more lingo if
your audience isn't quite as informed on
the subject
you're going to provide more background
information more hand holding
it's going to be like maybe a shallower
story with less detail
there's also what it is called the
consumption context or channel
your work isn't just for fun or
self-admiration you want to publish
something somewhere somehow
so whether you're creating a
visualization for the new york times
or the daily show or a bill's blog for
data dorks
it's going to change your approach one
might be more serious
maybe a higher standard of excellence
maybe more statistical integrity
the other might be more irreverent you
might have lower journalistic standards
you might round to fewer decimal places
with your numbers
it's not about being less accurate but
you may be less detail-oriented in
certain contexts
another issue is accessibility data
visualization is all about visualization
it's all about the eye we're only
dealing with sighted people correct
well yes and no you could say that you
could create a
quote unquote data visualization for the
blinds
but really it's just audio maybe there
are other ways of thinking about this
field
but there are other accessibility issues
also even if you don't go quite that far
the big one being colorblindness from
one to three percent of people are
colorblind
and there's an especially common form
called red green colorblindness where
people have difficulty distinguishing
between red and green
just think about stock market charts
where red is always used to mean prices
going down
in green for prices going up think about
what that might mean for the one to
three percent of people who have trouble
distinguishing between those two colors
luckily in trying to channel your
audience and understand what they're
going through
there's a great website to help you with
this
there's this website where you can
actually take an image and upload it
you can select an image from your hard
drive and it's going to show you what
the chart looks like
this is the original image over here and
then you can actually go in and click on
these little radio buttons
and see what it would look like for
people with different forms of color
blindness
it can help you channel your audience
and see what they would see
it's a great way to take a look at your
work and test it and make sure that
you're being friendly to all of your
audience
there are other things to think about
when you're thinking about the visually
impaired
a big one being contrast in font size
creating your charts with enough
contrast to be easily seen
making sure the font size is large
enough to be read
forget about visual impairment just
think about your audience
if they tend to be over forty years old
make sure your font sizes aren't 10
point
if your chart is for college kids don't
worry about it so much
the next thing to keep in mind is
whether or not your audience consists of
true believers or skeptics
or more often than not it's both but you
have to be aware of it
if you're visualizing data let's say
about climate change
to climate scientists it'll be received
differently than if you're sharing the
same data with a publication targeting
the coal mining industry
this is a dangerous lesson and that you
don't want to overthink how much
convincing you need to do
otherwise it might bias what you share
and how you frame it
on the other hand being aware of whether
you're sharing information to change
minds or simply to provide the truth
is good to understand because it might
affect how deeply you dive
and how much interactivity you provide
and finally
there is the action that you want your
audience to take
you're sharing your content for an
action a reaction from your audience
you need to know what you're looking for
what action you're looking for to design
better outcomes do you want someone to
call their congressman after looking at
your visualization
do you want them to answer a poll
question do you want them to share it
on social do you want to inspire them in
some other way
if you constantly ask yourself if your
design is leading toward this outcome
you're more likely to achieve it these
are all the things you have to
understand about your audience when
you're creating visualizations for them
but it's more than that it's not just
about understanding
it's about channeling them it's about
really getting inside their head
you don't want to ignore their culture
and accessibility issues and all these
other things you want to actually feel
their pain
you want to understand it as though you
are them
you'll be less likely to be influenced
by bias for instance because you're
going to feel their skepticism
their arguments against what you're
showing them it's going to help you
articulate more clearly and factually if
you can really imagine being them
imagine that you're them and you'll
communicate more meaningfully